[Musique]
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre sur tv
78 pour un nouveau point comme chaque
jour sur l'actualité yvelinoise voici
les titres de cette édition du journal
du 25 avril 2019 plus de contraintes
moins d'atouts les petites communes
peinent à trouver des policiers
municipaux les élus locaux espèrent une
réforme du système de recrutement nous
en parlerons tout à l'heure avec sylvie
souvent montré le maire adjointe en
charge de la sécurité à ville preuve à
200 mille personnes vivent avec la
maladie de parkinson nous avons suivi le
quotidien de pascal elle témoigne de ces
difficultés c'est notre portrait cette
semaine et puis enfin d'édition nous
irons sur les traces d' harry potter
lors d'une rencontre de quidditch ce
sport inventé pour les besoins de la
saga qui se pratique maintenant sur les
terrains yvelinois pour débuter à cette
édition je reçois donc sylvie ça va
monter bonsoir et bienvenue sur ce
plateau adjointe chargée de la sécurité
à villepreux est confronté à des
problèmes de recrutement pour votre
police municipale comme de nombreuses
petites communes à villepreux qui compte
onze mille habitants pourquoi est ce si
difficile aujourd'hui de recruter est-ce
que c'est propre
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs c'est il ya
plusieurs raisons à cela
déjà au niveau de la police municipale
l'aspect sécuritaire c'est déjà une des
priorités une des préoccupations
premières des français ça faut comme
déjà le redire donc du coup nous en tant
qu'élus locaux
vraiment au niveau des territoires c'est
la proximité c'est vrai que du coup de
nous la sécurité ça fait partie de nos
priorités en tant qu'élus locaux
ça c'est le premier point il c'est vrai
aussi que le contexte national
sécuritaire il ya toujours des menaces
très très accentué très marquée au
niveau du terrorisme et ça on peut pas
le on peut pas l'occulter
et donc forcément et je vous rappeler
par parler de tous les attentats mais
plus bataclan ça a vraiment changé la
donne au niveau des territoires
et c'est vrai que la plupart des
communes de notre taille ou plus grande
renforcent leur équipe de piste mais si
pâle comme ça c'est le premier point les
polices municipales grandisse se
renforce depuis déjà un certain nombre
d'années le problème c'est qu'on arrive
à un point où il ya plus de postes que
deux candidats donc ses sept premiers
points qui est logique par rapport à une
situation qui n'est pas parce qu'on vit
actuellement le deuxième point c'est que
l'on apprenne des recrutements alors le
fait qu'il y ait moins de policiers
municipaux que de peau c'est une chose
mais quand vous les recrutés par un
policier national 4n la place nationale
que la gendarmerie qui viennent la
pénitentiaire fois qu'il vient d'un
autre corps que la police municipale
l'atelier de leur forme est donc un jeu
remparts vif du sujet parce que c'est là
où on a fait avec le maire avec stéphane
mirambeau eaux montent au créneau ne
peut plus rester comme ça je vais
interpeller le président sur cette
exaction s'entraînant avec avenant macho
c'est une formation de six mois déjà
précisé savez les congés etc
le rivage qu'à huit mois donc quand vous
prenez quelqu'un va embaucher quelqu'un
qui vient la police nationale ça fait 15
ans qu'ils travailleurs plus nationale
pas dire qu'ils connaissent pas son
métier qui connaissent pas tous la
législation la presse new style match je
veux bien mais six à huit mois de
formation pour kafka qui est là depuis
10 ans ou depuis 15 ans au sein de la
police nationale ou de la gendarmerie
c'est juste pas possible donc idiot des
particules tout ça sans en plus des
formations aux frais du contribuable que
c'est la commune qui paye en plus de son
salaire
vous voyez un peu l'aspect financier au
stick est très lourd et donc en plus
c'est pas très motivant pour des gens
qui viennent d'un autre corps de
sécuritaire de se dire ah ça fait dix
ans que je serai sur le terrain on me
redemande de prêter informations six à
huit mois
donc ça vraiment apprendre de
recrutement c'est compliqué de recruter
à ce niveau là de plus on a un vrai
problème aussi niveau de la formation
parce qu'on a un organisme
cela c'est un organisme d'état c'est le
cnfpt qu'on connaît quand on connaît la
fonction publique territoriale ont fait
appel au cnfpt pour la formation des
agents et aux relents vous donne des
dates on vous recruter quelqu'un ça peut
être un an après la formation pendant un
an
votre votre agent il avec vous mais il
ne peut pas opérer sur le tapis on me
dit qu'au dernier qui avait offert huit
mois de formation mais il reste avec
nous dans le service
voyez un peu le côté mes vêtements
espèce de dysfonctionnements et d'
aberration totale que nous on subit
depuis des années alors après il part en
formation l'a pas pendant six à huit
mois après bourse hier il ya un trou au
niveau des effectifs qui est très
important là aujourd'hui la police
municipale de villepreux et en
sous-effectif ferralais relais 4 à lille
son 4 4 s'est passé avec le maire ce
qu'on souhaite savoir six agents donc on
en plein recrutement en espérant que ça
se fasse ça se décoince mais c'est pas
parce que ça va plus on espère aller un
peu mieux dans quelques semaines c'est
sans arrêt hyaric et pérenne parce que
tintin si vous faites une formation de 6
à 8 mwh peut très bien partir du jour au
lendemain car qui définit alors la vie
qui se coule sur que c'est pas compliqué
de recruter
vous l'avez formé cet état ne reflétait
pas une information notre portée parce
que c'est quand même mon tribut à la
collectivité et donc du coup après il
peut être à dessein à 10 ans qu'il se
passe rien il plus d'avoir un petit
dédommagement de la police de lattes de
la commune qu'elle récupère mais pour
l'instant il faut recruter
donc on remet le pied donc c'est très
compliqué ça fait des années qu'on
alerte
au niveau des niveaux local plus haut
niveau local et c'est vrai que la
plupart des collines sur les y visent
notamment quand on en parle on est tous
confrontés à ce problème là vous avez
interpellé donc le président de la
république le premier ministre
quelle réponse jusqu'à présent ministre
de l'intérieur nerfs on a eu des
réponses assez rapidement donc ça
c'était assez satisfaisant on était
assez content avec ses fans me rend
heureux d'avoir un retour assez rapide
le président de la république c'est son
cabinet qui a répondu en disant que bon
c'était très intéressant qui
transmettait sa mise à l'intérieur
edouard philippe premier ministre a
répondu qu'il faudrait une concertation
au niveau des statuts des agents au
niveau de la commission consultative des
polices municipales wade ont déjà qu'en
fait ce que c'est cette commission n'en
sais rien en tout cas il a quand même
stipulé que c'est quelque chose qu'il
l'interpellait il en avait conscience
mais qui renvoyait le bébé aussi amusé
castaner et monsieur qu'elle soit nous a
répondu qu'ils aient donné le dossier au
préfet donc là on en est là et de
l'autre côté ce que vous avez pensé
aussi peut-être une mutualisation
certaines communes peuvent le faire
mutualisé cette police municipale c'est
une piste à mais c'est une piste qui est
longue à mettre en place
on est dans un dans une période où la
plus nicipal nous qu une police de
proximité c'est un terme qui est utilisé
aussi par gouvernement qui me plaire peu
moyennement parce que nous la puce est
vraiment de proximité et les sortir à
toute la journée
c'est une véritable force de sécurité
qui est aux côtés de la police nationale
et la gendarmerie
donc la mutualiser oui mais ça va
prendre un temps fou
donc pendant ce temps là on ne peut pas
rester les bras croisés c'est vrai aussi
que on a un vrai sujet aussi parce que
et c'est ça qui doit déclencher avec le
stéphane mirambeau le fait qu'on
réagisse c'est qu'on a aussi la mairie
de paris
sac à déclencher en latérite et où les
fleurs et de son côté vouloir raconter
3000 allons tout d'un coup madame
hidalgo se prend de passion pour la
police municipale qu'elle a toujours
détesté depuis toujours et tout d'un
coup ou l'ifo le prisme et si pas la
vérité je crois 3000 autres missions
minerai donc j'avais peur que ça absorbe
des municipales personne n'est dupe
j'espère qu'ils ne sont pas dupes c'est
très électoraliste en fait c'est une
réalité dont elle va nous entre
guillemets c'est pas un très joli mot
même à nous dépouiller nos agents de
police municipale
donc c'est ça qui nous a vraiment qui a
déclenché notre envie de monter au
créneau d'alerter le président la
république et son gouvernement parce que
ça fait c'est ça en fait le sujet c'est
pas une réforme législative
c'est vraiment une modification de tout
ce qui est administratif et oui de haut
niveau de deux donc c'est pas c'est
assez facile à faire
c'est pas très compliqué à faire faut
juste s'y coller et que quelqu'un prenne
les choses en main hélas aujourd'hui
juste pour conclure vous nous dites que
sur la ville de villepreux le
recrutement va se faire rien vous dire
alors je rajoute quand même chose et que
bien évidemment on a alerté gérard
larcher président du sénat qui comme
elle le deuxième personnage de l'état
qui nous a répondu très rapidement
également qu'il allait saisir le
ministère l'intérieur est ainsi que ses
colistiers sophie primas lynche ni par
tati drac et michel laugier deux
sénateurs alors schmitt et michel
laugier ont posé des questions écrites
au gouvernement
donc on n'est pas tout seul et il ya
aussi lyon dès mardi divine qui est
intervenu donc voilà on attend beaucoup
des retours du gouvernement et
rapidement merci d'être venu nous parler
de cette situation sur le plateau je
rappelle que vous êtes maire ajointe de
villepreux en charge notamment des
questions de sécurité
merci à vous merci politique et le parti
socialiste en déplacement pour les
européennes aux mureaux dans le cadre de
la campagne eric andrieu député européen
candidat sur la liste envie d'europe est
venu découvrir la réalisation d'un
nouvel écoquartier et souligné
l'importance du local écoutez le
l'europe part du local ça j'en suis
convaincu je fais partie de celles et
ceux qui défendent ce qu'on appelle le
bottom up c'est à dire la phase
ascendante que l'europe des citoyens se
construit et cadeaux se construit à
partir de projets urbains et de projet
de territoire
j'ai un passé d'élu local de
maire de d'élu départemental d'élu
régional est ce que je constate au
niveau des politiques européennes c'est
que l' écoute n'est pas suffisante et
que nous devrions nous appuyer sur ce
type d'initiatives pour favoriser les
charges des bonnes pratiques à l'échelle
des vip des villes de l'union européenne
européenne toujours du côté du
rassemblement national à présent la
liste des soixante dix neuf candidats
est maintenant officiel jordan bardella
déjà conseiller régional d'île de france
reste à tête de liste et l'on retrouve
également en 22e position
mathilde andraud est la chef de file du
mouvement dans les yvelines
également conseillère régionale
d'ile-de-france et en 69e position le
maire de mantes la ville cyril note
d'ici le scrutin nouveau proposons
d'entendre régulièrement les candidats
sur leurs propositions pour mieux faire
votre choix après benoît hamon françois
xavier à bellamy nous sommes allés
rencontrer jean christophe lagarde pour
lui d i parce que l'europe c'est le seul
moyen pour d'un pays comme le nôtre pour
nos pays de se rassembler d'avoir une
puissance suffisante pour ne pas subir
les grandes puissances continentales qui
se sont installées dans le monde les
états unis la chine l'inde la russie et
quelques autres séparer nous allons être
débordés et il n'y a pas que face à des
pays et aussi face à de grandes
puissances économiques
songez par exemple qu'en matière
d'intelligence artificielle google une
entreprise américaine seul mais 15
milliards d'euros dans la sueur la
recherche cette année pendant que nos
pays séparé 27 pays met 8 milliards ça
veut dire qu'on va être l'arbre et
technologiquement si on ne se
rassemblent pas qu'on n'a pas une
politique industrielle commune
on a besoin
également de se renforcer pour protéger
nos frontières pour asb y ait un parquet
européen contre les terroristes et les
grands trafiquants on a besoin de re
d'augmenter le budget de la politique
agricole commune pour garantir notre
suffit de l'autosuffisance alimentaire
tous à nos pays n'ont plus le poids de
le faire seul
[Musique]
l'europe est en danger
elle peut disparaître contrairement à ce
que tout le monde pense et une de tes
raisons pour lesquelles dans nos
propositions nous cherchons des éléments
qui peuvent rassembler les européens
c'est parce que il faut reconstruire
cette unité comme jacques delors avait
su le faire à un moment où l'europe
était déjà en difficulté c'était dans
les années 80 nous proposons qu'il n'y
ait plus de contributions nationales
pour alimenter le budget européen
c'est 91 milliards pour andré à la
france mais c'est aussi beaucoup
d'argent pour andré aux autres remplacer
comme à l'origine comme du temps de jean
monnet par des contributions extérieures
une taxe sur l'importation de carbone
qui rapporterait 70 milliards une taxe
sur les transactions financières taxe
très minime 0 0 1% mais c'est bien
normal que ils contribuent au
fonctionnement de l'union européenne
il ya bien d'autres propositions pour
faire avancer l'europe car si elle
n'avance pas nous subirons le poids les
intérêts du reste du monde
et si ce sont leurs intérêts c'est que
ce sont pas les nôtres
[Musique]
nous proposons une europe qui se
rassemblent qui soit capable sur un
certain nombre de sujets de dire ça on
va le faire ensemble
je prends l'exemple des bateaux le
premier bateau à hydrogène autonome il
est français on devrait mettre le
maximum sur ce genre de technologie pour
permettre par exemple que demain on
risque plus de marée de voir comme on en
a vu encore il ya pas longtemps dans le
golfe de gascogne
parce que si un bateau fonctionne à
l'hydrogène si j'avais eu un accident
s'est jamais qu de l'an de l'hydrogène
dans l'eau l'hydrogène dans l'eau c'est
pas bien là rassemblés on peut à la fois
économiser les énergies isoler le
bâtiment développer la production de
d'énergie renouvelable et propre est
d'ailleurs en faire un secteur
d'exportation vis-à-vis de l'extérieur
mais on peut aussi utiliser le fait que
nous sommes une grande puissance
commerciale nous achetons beaucoup de
choses à l'étranger pour imposer nos
règles normes pour terminer cette page
politique un mot des municipales de 2001
à poissy où le collectif fois ci à
demain avec à sa tête
aymeric vallespir et et nathalie martin
ancien adhérent de la république en
marche et l'association vivons notre
ville qui compte deux conseillers
municipaux d'opposition ont décidé de
s'allier en vue de la future échéance
électorale au sein de leur programme
lutte contre tous les types de
pollutions participation citoyenne au
débat public et promotion du lien social
et intergénérationnel le portrait de la
semaine
à présent il est consacré à pascal
zimmerman atteintes par la maladie de
parkinson une maladie neurodégénérative
caractérisée par des tremblements au
repos ou encore des lenteurs dans les
mouvements de cent mille personnes sont
touchées en france manon varaldo a suivi
le quotidien de l'une d'entre elles
pour ses 50 ans le diagnostic est tombé
pascal souffre de la maladie de
parkinson
ça fait neuf ans que je sais que j'ai la
maladie mais vraisemblablement ça a
débuté une dizaine d'années pavant
troubles du sommeil
j'ai dit et dans ses mouvements traits
du visage qui se fige et perte de
l'odorat ont donné l alerte
j'avais un odorat extrêmement développé
et tout d'un coup plus de doha je me
suis aperçu aussi que quand je marchais
j'avais un bras qui ne balançait plus et
puis surtout les tremblements alors là
je clique et n'importe où j'arrivais pas
à mettre la crème sur le visage enfin à
touiller la salade les difficultés du
quotidien amplifie les symptômes de la
maladie de parkinson
pascal à son échappatoire streiff
accentue les symptômes de la maladie
le bruit de l'eau le bruit de la cascade
s'affaireront du bien c'est le second
point m imaginez les pieds pas prêt pas
peut-être des petites branches qui
craquent sentir les odeurs et se laisser
imprégner d'une énergie de renouveau la
pratique d'une activité physique douce
aide à contrôler et l'anxiété des
malades et à diminuer leurs symptômes
lâchez les mains et puis observer
observer comment vous vous sentez elle
est arrivée bien sûr avec ses douleurs
avec ses raideurs et puis à la fin de la
séance
c'était vraiment flagrant la halle elle
tremble et plus à cet instant pascal
prend de la dopamine toutes les trois
heures
elle a ce qu'on appelle des périodes on
off quand je suis en vain de doses alors
là je vois la maladie qui ressurgit à
grands pas et alors j'ai l'impression
d'avoir les boulets aux pieds
d'être complètement enfermé dans une
cage pascal ne se renferme pas sur elle
même elle reçoit ses amis une
préparation s'impose ne tousse est pas
trembler les douleurs provoquées par la
maladie peuvent modifier les rapports
avec l'entourage
la proportion de personnes atteintes de
dépression est beaucoup plus élevé avec
la maladie de parkinson que la moyenne
c'est quelqu'un qui a beaucoup de
volonté et je suis très admirative de
voir avec sa maladie tout ce qu'elle
fait elle recule la maladie elle l'a
fait reculer l oubli même si la maladie
se rappelle à elle se confie à des
personnes attendent des mêmes maux
france parkinson propose des rencontres
pour échanger et s'informer
pascal participe aux réunions de
rambouillet à 59 ans elle est consciente
que cette maladie neurodégénérative a
bouleversé sa vie ne dit pas je ne sais
plus faire ça il faut dire aujourd'hui
qu'ils arrivent à faire face
persévérante
elle profite de chaque instant au
maximum ne sachant pas de quoi demain
sera fait déterminée elle pratique la
danse en ligne depuis trois ans un
excellent exercice pour les personnes
atteintes de parkinson
la line dance ici on apprend vous avez
vu des chorégraphies avec des pas qui
font entre 32 et 64 temps par côté par
murat répéter donc pour la mémoire c'est
énorme et ça pour le cerveau je pense
que c'est vraiment important pour ces
personnes-là pascal s'est fixé un
objectif réussir entièrement sa
chorégraphie malgré la maladie est
envoyé sa performance à france parkinson
on reste dans le domaine de la santé
avec la maladie d'alzheimer et
l'initiative d'un accueil de jour qui
expérimente depuis deux ans maintenant
des solutions innovantes cette averse à
et l'hôpital de la porte verte est le
premier en france intégralement dédié à
une prise en charge non médicamenteuse
dégénérative incurable la maladie
d'alzheimer affecte gravement la vie des
personnes mais ici au centre de jour à
l'hôpital la porte verte à versailles
l'ambiance est détendue une soixantaine
de patients viennent un à deux jours par
semaine on va avoir comme ça des
activités qui vont pouvoir stimuler leur
sensation de bien-être stimuler aussi
leur mémoire
et puis aussi les maintenir dans un lien
social avec des personnes avec qui elles
peuvent partager certaines de ses
activités
dessin lecture ou cerceau il y en a pour
tous les goûts
les loisirs sont adaptés aux désirs et
aux capacités des personnes malades pour
améliorer ses services
un partenariat s'est créé avec le living
lab depuis deux ans cette structure
évalue les activités du centre de jour
avec l'aide des principaux intéressés
on travaille donc en lien avec les
professionnels et les usagers pour
développer les interventions
psychosociales où les interventions non
médicamenteuses en discutant avec les
personnes le living lab tests déjà des
activités comme la danse ou le tai chi à
terme l'organisation compte faire des
recommandations à l'hôpital la maladie
d'alzheimer touche 900 mille personnes
en france soit l'équivalent d'une ville
comme marseille second invité de ce
journal le responsable jeunesse et
citoyenneté de magny les hameaux bonsoir
bonsoir bienvenue sur ce plateau jusqu'à
la fin de la semaine vous proposer un
défi sport sport au pluriel à partir de
6 ans sur la commune
comment se déroule déjà cette opération
alors c'était cette opération a démarré
hier matin elle se déroule tous les
matins et tous les après midi donc de
10h à 12h et de 14h à 16h elle se
déroule dans un gymnase de la ville le
gymnase mauduit et on accueille tous les
enfants effectivement entre à partir de
6 ans et ce jusqu'à 13 14 ans uniquement
les enfants ou leurs familles sont
doivent accompagner alors les familles
peuvent accompagner il ya des enfants
qui sont pris en charge par les centres
de loisirs par le service jeunesse
il ya des enfants qui viennent aussi
tout seul quoi qu'il en soit en
demandent toujours au moins un numéro
pour avoir un contact
c'est la première organisation de ce
type sur la commune dont le but c'est à
chaque fois d'avoir des activités aussi
et pas faire on va dire un centre de
loisirs classique pendant les vacances
oui c'est ça ça c'est la deuxième
édition du défi sport c'est un événement
qu'on essaie de voilà de créer de
maintenir dans le temps et effectivement
ça permet aussi de proposer aux jeunes
de la ville un un petit événement un peu
particulier festif et sa relique
différents services enfants au sport
jeunesse citoyenneté
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya une petite
partie de l'éducation aussi éducative au
lycée on essaye toujours à travers nos
actions d'avoir une dimension éducative
pour transmettre quelque chose aux
enfants leur faire découvrir quelque
chose enfants et jeunes d'ailleurs donc
oui effectivement tous les services là
sont concernés par cet événement ce sont
des défis quel type de défi alors y'en a
plein il ya de l'adresse de l' équilibre
des jeux de force des jeux des équipes
des jeux de réflexion
l'idée étant ses devoirs pouvoir
mélanger tous les publics donc on a des
équipes mixtes avec des petits et des
plus grands
pour que ce soit déjà équitable et puis
et puis tout le monde se rencontre
surtout que les épreuves
et ça marche plutôt bien justement les
grands viennent aider les plus petits à
une certaine fraternité qui s'installe
un peu entre toulouse rend compte que
c'est un rôle que les grands aiment bien
endosser en fait celle les
responsabilise ça les valorise
1 et puis des forêts on a besoin des
petits défauts on a besoin des grandes
qui se rend compte aussi que voilà la
différence est importante et que ça fait
ça fait la force de l'équipe s'était
lancé en début de semaine vous l'avez
dit fréquentation plutôt bonne j'ai
bientôt comptant pour le monde ça va et
ça se terminera vendredi soir ce sera le
grand final s'est ouvert à toutes les
familles et on accueille toutes les
familles de 19h à 21h voilà une histoire
de pouvoir partager avec ses enfants
[Musique]
un moment un peu ludique il y aura un
espace restauration voilà tenu par une
association solidaire de la ville la
marche à suivre
et donc voilà ça risque d'être vraiment
très très sympa avec un laser game on
fait venir spécifiquement pour les
enfants uniquement pour cette opération
la willaya y arriver il vient il vient
demain et on le ferme après la soirée
alors c'est sûr transcription ou pas les
renseignements pratiques pour les
familles tout est ouvert uniquement aux
familles de magny les hameaux peut-être
aussi bien précisé voilà clairement par
contre non il n'ya pas d'inscription
particulière vous pouvez venir à partir
de 19h on sera là pour vous accueillir
pour vous proposer des animations
voilà pour les animations de cette
semaine et ce défi sport qui se
clôturera pour les familles de magny les
hameaux vendredi soir la semaine
prochaine d'autres rendez-vous aussi
classement la côte chaîne des
programmations au service jeunesse au
service enfance au service des sports
aussi donc encore voilà qu'un loup plein
d'activités à faire pendant les vacances
merci et d'être passé sur ce plateau je
parlais de cette initiative de la
commune de magny-les-hameaux merci à
vous et si vous aimez les défis sportifs
justement pourquoi ne pas tenter une
partie de quidditch sais pas si vous
proposez le genre d'activité sur magny
les hameaux
si et bien voilà ce sport inventé par
l'auteur de la saga harry potter a
aujourd'hui même sa propre coupe du
monde et le week-end dernier il y avait
un tournoi aux clayes-sous-bois organisé
par le seul club yvelinois manoir aldo
le quidditch est un sport de balle issu
de la célèbre saga harry potter et se
pratique avec un balai on utilise nos
balais à nos biens bien moldus donc ça
reste des tubes en pvc qu'on garde entre
novembre pour garder l'handicapant fêtes
du bas est sur le terrain l'objectif est
d'avoir plus de points que l'adversaire
en marquant un maximum de buts en
attrapant une balle magique le vif d'or
le gardien doit protéger les trois
anneaux et venir en renfort pour
soutenir les poursuiveurs ce sport aux
regroupe plusieurs disciplines
la magie du quidditch c'est de pouvoir
mélanger plusieurs sports pour en créer
un nouveau
et après on est sur des manipulations de
balles sur du dodge ball à on
américain on est sûrs d'eux mêmes
manipulations de ballon de volée sur
deux comment de la course au foulard
pour le vif d'or donc c'est plein de
plans de petits détails de sport
mélanger on en un seul créé il ya un an
et demi le club des 200 à participer à
sa première compétition officielle
samedi trois équipes se sont rencontrées
au championnat national de quidditch sur
le stade beltramini des clayes-sous-bois
cette année on a pu participer les
autres équipes ont été sympa de venir
nous voir
donc au clae d'en recevoir chez nous
pour la première fois est de permettre à
montrer aux clés que ben ouais on est
les seuls dans le 78 donc on a un
monopole est un privilège à avoir le
club comprend quatorze licenciés seniors
et une dizaine pour son équipe junior
c'est un sport mixte
c'est assez atypique et quand j'ai vu le
club au forum des associations
si oui bah quitte à faire du sport au
moins c'est atypique ça me plaît et
j'aime ce côté là ledley sound se fixe
un prochain rendez-vous un tournoi de
quidditch pour la lutte contre le cancer
du sein
une idée de balade si vous êtes moins
sportifs pour les prochains jours c'est
à dampierre le château a rouvert ses
portes au public les portes du parc une
initiative portée par le nouveau
propriétaire franky mulliez fondateur de
l'entreprise kiloutou et qui a fait
l'acquisition à l'an dernier du domaine
marylène yapi chinois nicolas d'andré
pour les images au beau milieu d'un parc
forestier de la vallée de chevreuse la
nature se laisse écouter on est au coeur
de la campagne et donc du coup quand on
sait d'oiseaux
si on a de la chance d'arriver quelques
fois où elle et chevreuils passé là et
puis on essaie de vue sur le château
isolé au calme le château de dampierre a
rouvert son parc au public depuis le 30
mars il offre une balade familiale sur
un territoire à l'histoire royal
l'histoire c'est la famille de luynes
qui devient duc de chevreuse et qui est
partir de ce moment-là veut construire
le château avec jules hardouin mansart
qui permet bien après cette famille
d'imposer son pouvoir sur cette vallée
de chevreuse et d'y recevoir la cour de
versailles
un aménagement permet aujourd'hui des
balades en calèche en rosalie une
voiturette de golf et même sur l'eau sur
les pas de louis 15
imaginez des chaloupes qui depuis le
château sont arrivés avec des
embarcations de paris
autre est une grande fête a eu ici est
donc cette ce pavillon sur l'île est
vraiment extraordinaire
il faut qu'il soit restauré évidemment
mais il est vraiment extraordinaire
parce que c'est cette petite folie posé
au milieu de l'île ma petite folie
mon petit grain de fantaisie
toi surprise dans les hangars un
ensemble de calais des voitures
hippomobiles sont conservées cinq
d'entre elles sont exposées au public en
attendant l'ouverture prochaine d'un
musée dédié
donc du coup on a exposé et bien
découpés de gala des calèches jusqu'au
break de chasse qui était tout le train
hippomobile pour la vie quotidienne des
ducs et duchesses de luynes au xixème
siècle le château de dampierre était
fermé depuis 2016 les yvelinois peuvent
de nouveau investir ces patrimoines et
1749 c'était toujours un moment en fait
très privilégié parce qu'on passe et
voir en ce moment à un pique-niqué
ensuite à jouer au football donc j'ai
vraiment des souvenirs vraiment réussir
de nouveaux souvenirs qu'ils se
construisent dans ce parc en attendant
l'ouverture du château lui-même ses
travaux de rénovation sont actuellement
à les tuer
c'est la fin de ce journal dans un
instant sur tv 78 de 7,8 loisirs avec
comme marraine iapichino pour vos idées
sorties nouveau point sur la formation
locale ce sera demain vendredi dès 18h
avec le 7-8 hebdo il sera principalement
question est des annonces du président
accompagné de la députée évinoise
béatrice piron très bonne soirée
[Musique]
non